unfälle schäden umgefallene bäume
menschen die sich durch den wind kämpfen
hier wir sehen in den erzgebirgskreis
mehrere autofahrer waren von
umstürzenden bäumen angeschlossen und
dort wird aufgeräumt aufgeräumt
aufgeräumt und es ist noch überhaupt gar
kein ende in sicht muss man sagen die
sind ja wie streichhölzer um gefallen da
auf der landstraße die bäume schwere
schäden vor allen dingen an
autos an häusern dort jetzt eben eben
aktuell auch im osten der republik der
heute früh noch verschont war und wir
schauen direkt zur gerd schröder uns
jetzt zugeschaltet aus ostfriesland denn
auch an der küste da gibt es
sturmwarnungen warnungen vor einer
sturmflut wie ist die situation gerade
bei dir
ja heute so angenehm ist hier gerade ist
eine neue organ front angezogen ist und
die böden deutlich angezogen es gab eine
kleine wird der beruhigung hier im laufe
des späteren vormittag aber jetzt sind
die orkanböen wieder voll da es gibt
einen kleinen sandsturm hier auch der
arzt hier gerade ins gesicht schlägt und
die flut ist da und das ist jetzt bilder
spannende wie hoch notiert auf es werden
zwei sturmfluten erwartet eine fahre
jetzt gegen gegen 12.30 und eine weitere
heute nacht und dann werden wir sehen
wie hochfläche auch bleibt im
hintergrund sehen wir den hafen von hd
hier und wir hatten ist inzwischen
gesperrt keine fähre kann rausfahren
aufgrund des hochwassers hier
jetzt offensichtlich das ist wirklich
äußerst ungemütlich ist aber schätzt uns
einmal für uns ein wie ist man dort
vorbereitet was trifft man dafür
vorkehrungen jetzt auch für die nächsten
stunden
norden ist ja sturm gewohnt also das
hier ist auch kein normaler strom mehr
wir haben hier orkanböen auch auf der
insel von
120 km/h gemessen auf der insel
wangerooge und die sturmfluten sind eine
große gefahr für die inseln weil bei
sturmfluten der sand von den inseln von
strecken und vor den bühnen abgetragen
werden kann es gab bereits vor zwei
wochen dort eine größere sturmflut mit
größeren abbrüchen und jetzt ist die
große frage wie weit laufen die
sturmfluten jetzt dorthin sind wieder an
und welche weiteren abbrüche sind dort
auf die insel zu erwarten
danke geld für die eindrücke dort aus
dem sturm aus dem orkan in ostfriesland
irgendwie gehen weiter jetzt in den
osten der republik dort hat der sturm
dort hat der orkan noch mal heftig
angezogen wir haben es am vormittag noch
relativ ruhig gehabt hier in berlin in
brandenburg in sachsen anhalt thüringen
das hat sich deutlich geändert und die
ganzen tag schon im sturm im orkan
einsatz des handels radigk großer
respekt du warst heute früh tatsächlich
oben drauf auf dem brocken hast dich
jetzt runtergekämpft schilder uns einmal
deine eindrücke von etwas weiter unten
hannes
danke mein respekt gilt vor allem den
freiwilligen helfern die wirklich wir
haben es gerade gehört seit 3 uhr 30
hier im einsatz sind rund um den brocken
im harz landstraßen wieder befreien von
umgestürzten bäumen hinter mir sehen wir
gerade eine bahntrasse die auch von
fichten von umgestürzten fichten
blockiert ist hier hat die feuerwehr
eben priorisiert sie hat gesagt wir
müssen erst mal die straßen frei räumen
weil hier auf beiden seiten der straße
zwischen tanne sorge und elend so heißen
die ortschaften geben menschen wohnen
und die müssen eben die für
rettungskräfte auch erreichbar sein wenn
es denn hier zum beispiel medizinischer
notfälle gibt eben gerade als wir diese
schalter aufgebaut haben haben wir
gesehen dass sie aus dieser fichten grob
oder hinten schon wieder weitere also
ungefähr anderthalb minuten sind da wie
der riesige fichten umgekippt
auch hier auf der anderen seite beni
wenn du einmal nochmal freundlicherweise
darüber schwenkt hier stehen noch zwei
einzelne fichten die schauer
lichtschranken und ich weiß nicht ob man
es erkennt in der kamera hier ist eine
schneise und der wind kommt also von da
hinten und kann eben ungestört
ungebremst in diese bäume hier rein
fahren wir sehen jetzt da hinten wie die
sich bewegen und eben hat es eben
wirklich knack gemacht wenn ihr hat ein
auge die ganze zeit auf den bäumen wir
haben das gerade verabredet wenn es
klappt macht dass wir dann rennen um
eben nicht selber jedoch zu schaden zu
kommen es ist zwar ein wenig weniger
strom aber die gefahr ist hier bei
weitem noch nicht vorbei weil der boden
eben total aufgeweicht ist weil die
wurzeln keinen halt mehr haben und
sobald jetzt ebenso eine nach bekommt es
eben immer noch zu tödlichen gefahren
kommen kann wir sind da
wenn man darunter liegt hat man
natürlich keine chance mehr dann hat man
vielleicht noch glück dass man gerade
sich entschieden hat zur rechten seite
zu rennen ich glaube es ist wirklich
besser wenn wir jetzt hier kurz
abbrechen und ich hoffe ihr habt
verständnis dafür und dass wir uns ja
auch in sicherheit bringen weil das
waren vielleicht gerade 25 meter hinter
uns und diese beiden bäume hier die
deutlich näher sind schaukeln und
schwanken auch erheblich hinter ihnen
sicherheit hannes das orkantief die lena
das hält deutschland fest im griff und
besonders betroffen ist der norden des
landes aber auch der osten des landes
hier in berlin in der hauptstadt
beispielsweise zum zweiten mal der
ausnahmezustand ausgerufen das bedeutet
die feuerwehr kommt nicht hinterher muss
also priorisieren kann also nicht alle
alarmrufe annehmen wir behalten
weiterhin die lage für sie hier im